I will sue and I will go public you
point your finger at me I point my
finger at you we are going to grind you
down man we are sanding the gears I hate
you do you understand that loud and
clear good Roman is an absolutely
fascinating character he really is and
you have also played him brilliantly
well thanks you're welcome all right
we're out of time that's perfect
that's it thank you that's it wow thanks
for taking the time to say that
Darren how do you manage to make Roman
so disturbing yet so vulnerable at the
same time a lot of that that's in the
writing that they see I think that
there's um it's really kind of amazing
about the shows right at the beginning
it felt like you know we were given this
great template this pilot but you know
there was room for us to sort of fill in
our own gaps uh I remember not even like
asking questions I just sort of made
decisions for myself in terms of Romans
like backstory of the kind of thing
person he was and waiting to sort of be
corrected but between the pilot and then
them writing episodes like two and three
it seemed that they had
paying pretty close attention to what
the actors had done with the material
that Jesse gave us and started writing a
bit toward it and the biggest example of
that I would say is Connor I think
apparently they're publishing the
scripts like they're coming out but if
you look at the pilot script Connor is a
pretty blank slate and could have just
been the older brother who's around
occasionally normal guy and Alan came in
with something I did not see on the page
at all and this very eccentric odd man
almost kind of spooky to be around and
that was just something Alan brought and
by the time we got about a year later I
was like oh this is this is Conor now
it's different they have Alan's voice
now and they have whatever Alan was
doing which was weird they started
writing to so he really helped create
that character I think with the writers
so they started doing that with my voice
and with everyone else's so it was sort
of like discovering it together and I
always felt like I had a voice if
something felt off and I could always I
could always speak up and it was never
really a fight I could just say I
actually don't think
uh Roman would do that or although
got really lucky uh in that and I told
Jesse this like last year I think uh I
said whenever there were I would have an
issue when like the first script would
come I would keep it to myself because
it's a table you draft and then we'll
get the official draft later a lot of
those Corrections will be made and
sometimes the night before we're about
to do the scene and I have an issue with
it because I don't think Roman would do
it we would get a rewrite at like 1am
and he caught it himself and would fix
it so I wouldn't even have to say it
there was it was so like synced up like
he would look at me like hmm perhaps a
little more focused eye Roman wouldn't
do that and they didn't have to and if I
did uh he would sometimes give a counter
argument as to why he thought Roman
would do something
uh but he wanted to hear me out and we
would usually come to an agreement right
then and there sometimes we would sort
of try both or try his or try mine and
you know whatever and find it there's
one this year that I can't talk about
where it was a red flag from the
beginning that they had Roman just like
walking away from something that I
didn't think he would walk away from and
I brought it up and I brought it up and
then Jesse like put it in the script
which was really nice he like he changed
his mind in the script and I said but do
you want
both and he goes I'm not sure yet I put
yours in just because that makes sense
to you so we'll know on the day if
that's going to be something you do and
we tried my way and he didn't want he
said if that to him that felt true for
Roman to do and so by putting in the
script and seeing it he was like that's
what we're going to do and then we
actually took it one step further where
I asked mylet actually I think I want to
do something else can we film both
versions uh so we filmed the way that I
it's it's hard to talk about without
being specific but we filmed I don't
want you to spoil it I know but we
filmed the way that I had pitched I said
which one do you want to do first the
the scripted or the one that my idea and
he goes just let's do your idea because
it's easy to just sort of move you from
it later so we did it we did like two or
three times and I said do you want a
movie because actually I talked to Jesse
and I think we think that this is
great this is what Roman would do and it
was really nice to be like that wasn't
in the script it just felt like instead
of keeping myself going um in my gut I
really feel like I would do this but the
script says not to I just spoke up and
they said try it and then they saw it
and went yeah that is what Roman would
do that's that's like an amazing thing
you just don't get no no no it's huge
when an actor has that kind of voice and
as well as development of a character
and is allowed to express that behind
the scenes and not and it's not just
like a certain like tier people I think
like you know when a day an actor comes
in for a day if they have a question
they speak up like they they want to
collaborate with every actor that's in
it's not like a you're you're you're
this character you don't get to speak
it's like everyone we're all here trying
to make this thing better and it's he he
must know that he's a very talented
writer and that he he he must know that
but there's no ego involved it's not
yeah I wrote This brilliant thing you
have to make it work your job is to make
my words work it's like oh that's
interesting why wouldn't you he wants to
hear that
you know that keep keep their keep the
real everybody you know we're all
working on this thing together it's very
like handmade it's his but he's like he
doesn't have an ego he goes help me I'm
making this thing help me absolutely and
you've made this character your own in
fact just the trajectory of Roman from
the season three season finale to all of
the scenes and the trailers and things
that we've seen for season four he's
gone through a lot yeah there's a
there's a lot so where where is he at
the start of season four where is he
with his siblings and what is his
relationship going to be now with Jerry
yeah I know with the with Jerry you know
I don't know because I've never I don't
even know what it has been in the first
place I still haven't quite figured out
what that is it makes sense in my belly
but I don't really know what that is
um and then in terms of like the
siblings I think it's actually something
close to healthy for once you know I
think we've been
sort of competing with each other and
just been sort of under dad's
you know spell a bit because
we love each other but have no means to
sort of Express that or show that with
each other We're not gonna like get
together and hang out like we we always
needed the business
to hang out with each other I think
Roman doesn't really have anyone else I
think he has his siblings and the people
he works with I don't think they're like
friends he doesn't have a partner
there's nobody else so he needs the
business in order to have relationships
with people including the ones he loves
so when he gets cut out he at least gets
cut out with his siblings and it's like
well we have each other but we can't
just hang out we need something so we
form a business together we're putting
this thing together just I I think yeah
I think it's a good idea and it's it's
good to you know have her own business
and be our own people and be separate
from Dad but I think it's more so that
for Roman anyway it's more like so I can
keep hanging out with you guys and we
can have a relationship because
otherwise if we don't have anything
we're never going to see each other if
we have our own business and it's
successful we do that there's potential
to have a relationship with Dad now that
we're not
working for him we can actually like I
think for Roman anyway I don't know if
somebody's feel the same way it's like
yeah Dad heard us but also you know I
think I wanna
I'd like to get to a place where I'm
seeing him on his birthday or you know
Thanksgiving and stuff I think I'd like
it to get back to hanging out with Dad
and if we have our own business then
maybe we can get together and have a
scotch and talk about our uh our our
different companies and ask for advice
here and there and have you know give me
one thought on uh this new season
without Jerry Who's basically pushed
herself away from you or your character
at the end of season three give me one
thought on what that did to Roman I
think in that moment Roman was hurt by
Jerry but also she's always gonna make
the Practical Choice the right business
decision and the thing that's right for
her she says it so I think he
understands I think when we start this
it's a couple months later and I think
it's like I feel like it's I feel anyway
no actual hard feelings toward her I
think whatever that thing is he has has
had for her he still has I don't think
it's like a betrayal it's like a well
you know
we came after Dad and we lost and you
picked aside because you picked the
right side because it's best for you
that makes sense he's on the floor tom
explaining what he's doing he's moseying
terrifyingly moseying it's like if Santa
Claus was a hit man I love this show I
love cousin Greg
why why do you like it why do you love
him I would like to hear from you
because I'm trying to figure it out
still like
why do you tell me well I personally
think and you've kind of alluded to this
a little bit I think we might be
watching the best villain origin story
of all time like I think he's been nice
and observant and everything from the
outside for so long but I really feel
this season that Greg is going to really
let loose now am I wrong can you tell me
I cannot tell you uh that is for sure
but I like your theory I like your
theory a lot uh I think when it's kind
of human nature right when somebody's
like bullied or punished you know or
whatever shamed enough like eventually
they're gonna come for you so let's
let's see what happens he's he's been
hazed a lot yes he has okay well can you
answer this
um what has excited you the most about
playing this version of Greg it's really
fun it's been fun to just grow him grow
his maturity and and sort of chip away
at his goodness over time that morality
that he had in the first season and so
it feels like this was an opportunity
for us to really like I personally
wanted him to have like a sharp haircut
and nice bespoke suits and crisp shirts
that fit me really well and and you know
good shoes and nice watches that cost a
lot of money and I think all that stuff
it's a nice way to to kick it off
there's been about three months maybe
between the end of season three and and
the beginning of season four and he's so
confident being on the Logan side so
like clearly that uh that it felt right
to just you know what would Logan want
him to look like how you know you have
to represent the Logan side so I can't
be I have to show up and be somebody
that that he wants to be next to so yeah
so that was that was fun and then and
you'll see sort of how he is as a man
this year so it sounds like this season
it's really he cares way more about what
Logan thinks than Tom yeah I think so I
mean
I think he's got his relationship with
Tom already if you're close to Logan
that's that's the thing you're drawn
towards the most uh I think Greg knows
Tom is gonna punish him and and
um
and keep him below him in the pecking
order
but
but I think Logan being close to Logan
endearing
himself to Logan's always the goal but
he thinks that and then Tom continues to
be a pain in the ass for Greg
of course because you know the
disgusting Brothers they have to
there's nothing he's the disgusting
older brother yeah who came up with that
by the way and how did you find the
right way to like say it
that the writers was that you that is
the writers that would that would be a
crazy improv to bring in to the show
um I wish I had but uh yeah that was all
them looking back what do you think is
the worst thing that Greg has done on
the show and what do you think is the
worst thing Greg's had done to him on
the show the worst thing that Greg has
done on the show
is
try to sue Greenpeace I guess that's
that was epic that's a pretty horrible
thing to do and the worst thing that's
happened to Greg
is probably getting thrown into the snow
and slapped around by Tom at the end of
season one I think that's the worst
physical abuse than the water bottles
getting thrown at him but those yeah
those those two
that's real physical harm so what would
it look like if Greg does like get
Logan's eye and become the successor
what would be the first thing he would
do you know he's he probably would
try to do logany things and feel
kind of fake or something but I maybe
he's just like a really good CEO and
like a great guy I don't know these are
not theories I'm not liking any of these
theories you can scratch all this this
is none of these are good that's
you should ask Jesse please ask Jesse
well I don't think I don't think Greg
would be able to do any of this without
Tom I don't think he'd be a good leader
if Tom was still there because Tom would
be vying for uh Power right yeah oh yeah
yeah yeah Tom would be pulling a lot Tom
would probably try and get Greg
assassinated uh if if Greg was the CEO
and not him so okay so let's say that
that he isn't the successor but let's
say Tom and Greg get their own spin-off
show would it be a rival company you
know that's a good that would be a good
way to do it
they could they could start their own
company I don't know where if anyone
would give them money to start a company
but it'd be you know be fun to watch
those guys in like a an indie movie like
a road trip movie through you know
Russia oh my God
that would be insane so okay
I know you can tell us what Greg does in
season four can you give us a hint as to
what Greg observes about each sibling
this season because the end of last
season Kendall chiv and Roman basically
got their butts handed to them does Greg
and proximity to them is he their
antagonist now or does he still trying
to is he still trying to be on recon and
get information out of everybody I think
Greg has never fully loyal to any side
so do with that what you will I I yeah I
think he he's always looking for the
best
card to play the best side to be on and
I think he's
always Gathering data and trying to to
be a little schemey uh in all ways so so
he's he's not he's he's never fully
against anyone I don't think gotcha you
have made this character like cousin
Greg is now like an icon it will down in
history this character that you have
created so very kind you're very welcome
what does it what did it feel like on
the last day of shooting yeah the last
day
last day was really weird
because it felt it felt good that I had
really good lasts there were my last
scenes story wise so it felt really good
to finish with that
and then I thought I was just gonna be
like cool thanks everybody you know
see at the premiere and then when we all
wrapped you know they call your names
out and the whole crew claps and
everything I got really emotional and
and you know you look around and you
just
think about how many years I've been
working with this person and how great
they are at their job and how much
they've I've learned from them and gone
through with them and
you know needed them it's you know you
kind of like
wardrobe and props and and all you know
to the director and Jesse it's like you
need help from all these people in order
to do your job well and um and so it's
pretty amazing what everyone puts into
this life you know making TV making
movies you know people like don't get to
see their families when we travel to
Croatia or or Norway they don't get to
be with their kid you know covet season
was really hard for for um the crew and
everybody so
I think that I felt a lot of gratitude
and and
um and just yeah it's kind of it was
unbelievable to feel like I'm never
gonna see this group again I'll probably
see a lot of these people in other jobs
separately but this group is is done so
it's pretty yeah felt really big all of
a sudden imagine I try to do people turn
against me
I'm 100 feet tall
[Music]
these people are pygmies the pilot of
succession began with Logan's 80th
birthday party and the premiere for a
successions final season also begins
with a birthday party for Logan this
time though with the exception of Connor
his children aren't there how does that
affect him oh he's very sad about him he
would like his kids to be there but his
kids are so recalcitrant they cannot
step up to the plate and uh it's a
source of great sadness for Logan you
know
that's why we see him when he meets the
one person who's been most apart from
Kerry his new Love or Whatever her
relationship is is column you know his
constancy over the the whole four series
and he goes you know you're my best pal
you know the person you know and that's
a it's such a sad State It's a Wonderful
acknowledgment of of that character
because of his his concerts and he's
never meant he doesn't make any demands
he's got no ulterior motives he just
does his job and that's actually all
that Logan wants he wants people to do
their job without all kinds of agendas
at place or all kinds of you know futile
Ambitions at work and that's the problem
with the kids
is they want something else they need
some kind of
um Assurance of something you know that
there and without making any effort in
terms of the responsibility
and the Sun and so they're kind of
crippled by their own avarice really and
he can see that and he can understand
that he's not a fool he understands how
difficult it is for his children it's
like you know especially I mean you know
I'm an actor my eldest son is an actor
and I know how difficult it is for him
to have his father who's quite a
well-known actor and he's my my son
Allen is a brilliant actor and actually
now he's at the age of 50 somebody
coming into his own in a wonderful way
but it's been a long haul for him and
it's been difficult for him so I know
what that's like what that parent-child
relationship is about and these kids
have just they want to circumvent so
much as
I think it's a quote from Macbeth
vaulting ambition which all leaps itself
and falls on the other side and then and
then he talks about jumping the life to
come and I think that that's what
they're doing they want to jump the life
to come they don't want to experience
their responsibility they want all on a
plate and he just says it ain't like
that you're going to understand it's
hard work it's a lonely business you
know when you have a vision of an Empire
even though it is the antithesis of any
Empire I believe in
but it still his Empire and he has to be
given
Credence for that and the kids ain't
doing it well and he says that you know
I love you all but you're just not
serious people not serious people
absolutely well spotted not that's one
of the key things you're not serious
people and I think that's very true I
think that's true and yeah because he
comes up for I mean they all they all
love to hate Logan I mean the audience
of oh he's a brutal you know do tell me
to off you know all that on a
regular basis I get all the time could
could you just tell me to off
please and I'll off you know
it's it's true so you've had people on
the street actually walk up to you and
ask you to say that to them all the time
all the time people come up to me and
they take out their their iPhones and
they point in my direction and say can
you please tell me yourself and I go
yeah that's the easiest thing in the
world off
you have mentioned that the dinner with
Kendall from season three was one of
your favorite scenes when he tells him
life's not nights on Horseback it's a
number on a piece of paper it's a it's a
fight for a knife in the mud what did
that reveal to you about Logan well how
tough It's been you know it is a fight
for you know it doesn't have to always
be like that but that's been his
experience that's what he's gone through
and the kids don't I mean kids they
don't realize what you as a parent have
gone through they don't realize the
sacrifices that you've made in order to
be the person you are and create the
family that you want you know and it's
tough it's not easy and I think that
that's that slogan that's where Logan
tells the truth it isn't nights on
Horseback it isn't you know somebody
coming in and you know and wearing a
lady's favor and claiming the day it
ain't it's that's bollocks you know it's
a tough tough business and that business
especially in the media business is
really really tough and then all the
inherent stuff and the boat you know
when he he and he finds out about that
stuff and he's an innocent Logan he said
I didn't know what was going on I mean
that kind of stuff has never been you
know I'm I'm not into that he's not I
mean he's he's had his Affairs and he's
you know he's had his relationship with
with members of the opposite sex but
he's never gone into that sort of taking
advantage of situations but clearly that
has happened and and actually there's so
that there is also something quite
innocent about Logan too at the same
time he's that he's not
he's not what he seems to be you know
now will any of the children be the
successor or will it be Greg will it be
Greg I don't know it's a bit like the um
you know the pope deciding on the pope
you know the smoke hasn't gone up the
chimney yet
that's true and and the other thing
about the pope is something
yeah exactly
exactly
succession after four seasons has had
such a profound effect on pop culture
what does the series mean to you looking
back on it now and what was the last day
on set for you like you know the last
day on the set was it was difficult
because not for me but for everybody
else you know going oh this is the last
day oh dear I'm not just so much the
last day on the same I'll put it on
Monday you know I mean I've had a long
and great career I've been I think I'm
one of the luckiest people ever to have
the career that I've had you know I mean
really the work that I've done over you
don't dwell on that but you go God I
played that and I played that and I go
oh my God I forgot I did that you know
it's amazing you look back you go
thankful and then when you come to
somebody like this show
I mean it's certainly the icing on a
incredible cake you know and you go wow
you know this pond that's I mean as soon
as it as soon as the thing was pegged to
me I thought this is one of the great
roles of old time and I just have to
keep my nose to the grindstone and make
it work and it's been a gift and a joy
and so I've I've been very happy and I'm
very grateful I I do there are certain
elements to where I I was I was nicely
Anonymous before you know
2018. I was nicely Anonymous I mean I
was the guy who went when you and no
that wasn't you what do you did you do
oh no that wasn't yeah we didn't oh no
no that was who I was but now
Logan Roy has stolen my you know
anonymity well I think you've done an
incredible job and no I knew you as
Striker I knew you was a lot of other
characters too
well that's what I'm you know that's
what I'll go on to because you know it's
only a stop along the way and my view is
you know we need to practice our craft
well I don't understand the actor only
does one film a year or one job a year
and I go when are you practicing what
are you doing you know I love the game I
love the job I love every aspect of it
the voiceovers the work and I want to be
practicing all the time
and I've been blessed I'm very I'm
really very grateful for this last
in a few years it's been a joy and it's
been an honor to do you cannot win your
dad will wash you away this is a chess
board are you tanking the deal and every
move is crucial I love your character on
this show because I think she's always
the smartest person in the room as we
head into season four we're looking at
all these experiences that Jerry has had
with the way star warco family including
being interim CEO where does she see
herself in the company now well that's a
good question because at the end of
season three everything sort of blows up
in her face and everyone's face you know
but she's on the Alps with both Logan
and Roman and it's it's very precarious
um so I think
that when season four starts and
actually sort of the whole season
there's a feeling of her being in limbo
and not really being on firm ground so I
don't know I mean I do I think of her as
this I don't know as the smartest person
in the room too in a way and uh but I
think that she's
she's not a Roy she does not
she doesn't have the authority to make
things go her way and I don't know that
as I've said before I don't think she
particularly wants to be
the the on the throne and have the
target be on her back like I think she
operates best behind the scenes but I
think she sort of doesn't know who her
comrades are at the moment you know yeah
I mean especially after that last
Revelation for Roman uh who you know
sort of reached out like help us and
Jerry really kind of turned him down
like what yeah what are my interests
yeah how does this help me but which I
tried to teach him to do for himself so
has she cut basically that tether their
relationship is morphed into many things
but that connection with Roman what does
that look like now because you know
we're all fans of this couple
well I think at the start of the season
it's definitely very very they're very
frosty with each other and Jerry's sort
of odd man out in general in the company
but there are a lot of dynamics that
keep shifting during the season
that Jerry and Roman still have to so
they still have some stuff to go through
I don't know if Jesse agrees with me but
I think that uh whereas she keeps
rebuffing his his advances which I don't
think he even
I don't know what he'd do if if Jerry
said yeah let's go get a hotel room I
think he's chicken out you know but I
think that you know she somehow or
another she has affection for him and
maybe just because I have so much
affection for Karen but I feel like he
did get under her skin and she really
did want a protege and she really did
think he'd be a good
um front man for a way star and she'd be
his like the brains behind the beauty
you know
um and I think she's very disappointed
about that and and so I do think she
aches a little bit for him but she'd
never admit it no not in a million years
not in a million years exactly but you
did mention that she is not a warrant
and that she is navigating this universe
a little bit as an outside an outside
Insider but she is the only other woman
besides shiv that really has that
high-ranking position do you think if
she had nurtured shiv versus
Roman that shiv might be kind of better
I've thought that many times I've
actually thought that many many times
but
um
I don't think shiv
whatever the psychology is there between
shiv and her mom or or I'm not sure what
it is I thought I don't think I
feel like shiv
acknowledges Jerry's um
powers or or abilities but she doesn't
seem to trust her and she so I but I do
think Jerry
I I mean I think Jerry's opinion we've
never seen addressed this in the show
but if if left to me to answer that I
would say she does notice that shiv is
quite bright but shiv is very rash too
and she's not experienced and she's very
judgy so she might not have the the
temperance needed I don't know do you
know what I mean yeah I feel like it's
it's the ball would be in shiv's court
to to ever start anything like that and
it's it's shiv is not very
trustworthy with her the end of season
three right away after the um
phone the text incident
uh in Italy right away she's trying to
get me in trouble
with it you know for not having reported
to HR
and it's quite ugly and it's you know I
mean I love that scene I loved acting
that scene with Sarah but I feel like
Jerry who always is good at poker face
is like
All She Wants To Do Is end the
conversation and get the ladies
restroom and have a good cry or scream
or something you know
she's just so awful that Santa many
people have told me even men have told
me like oh the women at work say that
scene articulated something so familiar
and I've never seen it presented on the
screen before like that that
confrontation between two women at work
and that massage
misogyny Between Women almost you know
yeah it's that internalized misogyny
absolutely yeah you know it's a brief
scene but a lot of people have pointed
that out to me women and men have uh
said like you know that that hits that
hit it on you know right on the nail
right the nail right on the on the head
there the other thing that we saw this
season was a glimpse of Jerry's personal
side you know the when she takes a
picture of herself to send her daughters
are we gonna see more of that this
season we see more of Jerry's real life
I don't know Jerry plays Everything very
close to the best and she keeps that
stuff pretty private
um
you see a little bit of it a couple more
questions what do you think Jerry's
thoughts are on Tom after the season
finale what if she plays him now I can't
answer that I have to plead the fifth uh
oh okay I can't talk about how I feel
about any of them at the end because
that would be telling but um I think
she's always thought that Tom got true
mercenary ability he could be a real
Soldier you know and that he's but
what's so interesting about Tom and I
don't know if Jerry knows this is just
how
um the death he's such a seems like such
a shallow character
and then the depths of healing he has
about shiv and a lot of people and even
Greg or Logan you know he he's he's a
really interesting character and I don't
know that the others give him credit for
that they all treat him like a grown-up
frat boy which is kind of you know his
outer self Jerry's character was
completely different when it was
scripted and you've even mentioned that
character is only supposed to be in a
few episodes
you have completely transformed her and
made her your own what was it like the
last day on set
I'm gonna start crying right now uh it
was horrible we were all sobbing I mean
it was just we've all had this like
incredibly Rich experience and you're
right I do feel like
this is a unique experience for me I do
feel like I have some ownership over the
part and like I really did kind of think
her up and to a degree I mean the you
know the writers set the
set set the scene for that and then but
then and then kind of endorsed what I
came up with is how I'd put it and wrote
for that but I do feel like it's just
one of those times in a career where you
just feel like
so proud of this and this has just been
so satisfying to work on and when I
watched the premiere last night I was
like the show is dazzling in my opinion
it's just so beautifully shot and the
performances and the the dialogue is so
crisp it's like
I don't know I mean how are you going to
get all those things
again I mean it's like the planets have
to align you know
so everybody's a little sad I mean it's
a tight rope walk on a straight razor
500 foot reputational drop
your character honor is so fascinating
to me and I think it's because of how he
positions himself or how they Place him
in the show he is a Roy but he doesn't
participate in a lot of the crazy
sometimes but he knows like who they are
so like at the end of season three
Conor's the only sibling like not trying
to overthrow Logan and then at the start
of season four he's the only sibling at
the birthday party how do you think he
feels about that and his position within
this family historically throughout the
show Connor has always sided with Logan
no matter what the schemes were with
with Kendall or with the other two he's
always come down on the side of his
father
um I think that Connor really loves his
brothers and his sister but he doesn't
trust them at all they've used him uh as
sort of a an object of ridicule for all
their lives uh he's dismissable you know
and uh early on uh Conor realized he had
no aptitude for this Cutthroat business
stuff and um he had a lot of money
because the old man set him up so he
didn't have to work so he divorced
himself from that world and uh he's
basically letting the others pick
themselves apart squabbling and fighting
with each other trying to get control of
this Empire and
um when there have been votes you know
the kids need to vote on something he's
whatever you guys decide whatever you
decide you know but historically he's
he's always sided with his father
um so that's not a surprise at the
beginning of this uh fourth season that
he would be the only one at the birthday
party because the uh you know the other
three uh feel absolutely betrayed and
they were they were betrayed by their
mother
because she was making a deal for her
new husband
um and they're just desperate
to get their hands on a way star royco
um and we'll see what happens
but uh uh I don't think anything has
changed in terms of his feeling toward
his father or or toward the kids and
toward his siblings okay now what we did
see in the trailer is that we are
getting a wedding so Willa and Connor
finally got engaged last season and now
we're getting the wedding this season
you've said that Connor swords sort of
creates his own reality you know he's
got his own money when it comes to the
real world what reality has he sort of
created in his relationship with Willa
and how does it differ from the truth he
still is entitled an elitist as as the
other kids he's he's still you know and
he just
he has no idea what the real world is
and he's also he suffers from delusional
disorder he probably well it still does
have ADHD he's got a lot of things going
on so he has trouble comprehending what
real life is and um when he was young
the uh the divorce happened between
Logan and Connor's mother he was left
with his mother probably for 10 years
who was in and out of Institutions he
was off at boarding school so very early
on he created a fantasy world for
himself that continues to this day and
the money has always been there to
enable that I don't think Connor really
has much of a grasp on what we might
call reality occasionally Willa reminds
him even though she's delusional as well
she'll remind him of different things
and it brings him sort of back down to
earth a little bit but he's uh he's
always going to be kind of floating
around and spiraling he's not he's not a
grounded person yeah no in any way shape
or form exactly also the boys tend to
have some eventful weddings we'll uh
Connors be a spectacle as well
yes
[Laughter]
Financial candidacy has been highly
entertaining could you imagine if he won
though
that would be the end of the United
States as we know it it would be up for
grabs and there would be a coup of some
kind and you know it might be uh the
military might take over who knows it
could be you know horrible now I heard
through the great find that you met an
actual president I I have uh a friend in
Los Angeles our kids uh our friends her
name is Jen polenzani and she's a an
advanced person for uh Joe Biden in Los
Angeles and so one day at school uh she
said would you like to be in a
presidential motorcade and I was like
yeah I mean what do I have to do and um
she said what they do is they uh they
fly the president and a select team of
security and Military and dignitaries to
whatever City he's going to around the
world
um and then they supplement the drivers
with local people so I wound up being
driving a press van in the motorcade it
was big fun because
um you know the motorcycle cops clear
the way and you just blow through those
street lights you just keep moving man
it's just like stay on the tail of the
car in front of you it's Follow the
Leader it was a lot of fun did you
actually get to meet him I did it was
very brief and we had masks on so I mean
you know he was like good to see you pal
but we couldn't even shake hands because
it was still kind of uh coveted was
rampant so he had a mask on I had a mask
on we took a picture I don't even know
where that picture is that's awesome I
was told not to share it with anybody
for security reasons
that's you Connor would though oh yeah
yeah it'd be on uh Twitter Instagram
something
um we were introduced to Justin Kirk's
Jared menkin uh last season and it looks
like we're seeing more of him this
season what does he bring out of Connor
oh jealousy uh uh he he raises uh
Conor's hackles I guess you could say
because he uh he's just a very slick you
know really intelligent guy with a
forceful personality so he's got a lot
of stuff that Connor doesn't have
stuff that Connor covets like he walks
into a room Jared menkin walks into a
room and people take notice and Connor
would love to have people react to him
that way but um it's probably never
going to happen now even with members of
his own family he would like especially
with them
um now last season Logan told Kendall
that uh life is a fight for a knife in
the mud
now while Conor had a knife but it was
more like a butter knife
it actually was a butter knife yes and
he waved it in the face of his siblings
in the season three finale now
juxtaposing that metaphor with the
butter knife scene what does that tell
you about Connor
related to season four and I know we're
not getting Beyond this but what does
that tell you about Conor's future
Connor
really doesn't possess killer instinct
which all the rest of them have in you
know
implantitude so he doesn't really have
that and what you'll what we've seen
throughout these seasons is Connor
occasionally stands up to his brothers
and sisters and basically tells him to
fo you know I've had enough of you just
leave me alone or whatever he makes a
little stand and then he always comes
back to them yeah because he doesn't
have anybody else
he has Willa which is you know she was
sent from God God sent Willa to to
Connor but um he has no friends he has
no friends
and he uh he constantly comes back to
his father and to his brothers and his
sister because that's all he has so uh
we've seen him
you know tell them off and then come
come sort of shuffling back
how you guys doing
what was the last day on set like you've
spent so much time with this character
what was that like it was really
emotional everybody uh um
we had two scenes that I was in that day
and uh in between takes people were
getting very weepy
you know and um
you know it's because it all meant
something and we all love each other so
you know uh when they said it was
Justine and Allen's last day there were
tears popping and then there's a giant
hug of I don't know how many people like
this and that was hard to let go
so you know but that just means it was
real